une coucougnettes une coucougnettes la
réponse est une coucougnettes quelle est
la question
oui kelly qu'est-ce qu'ils ont dû manger
dans koh lanta vendredi
non merci vous avez regardé koh lanta
vendredi non merci
will est la spécialité culinaire de je
ne sais plus quelle ville dites-nous
mais non je n'ai pas la ville mais c'est
la coconnière bien merci oui tiens
qu'est-ce que vous avez raconté comme
année donc est ce que vous vous êtes
blessé ce matin lama et difool un rasoir
à la main j'ai entendu coucougnettes
qu'est ce que vous dites non en fait
deux de quoi avez vous parlé ce matin
dans la matinale de skyrock avec
diffuses concernant votre matelas vous
l'avez bien raconté d'ailleurs et je
n'ai pas on ait marre de l'escroquerie
je craque c'est pour mais bon là le
point voilà ça c'est fait vous allez pas
escroquer tout beau tout va les régler
regardez là c'est vrai bonne réponse de
raymond et je veux me raser un peu voilà
et tu vois les pouliches est bullish
exactement et ici je suis ricains avec
une tondeuse et tu vois pas et je
t'explique sesquières j'étais bien venez
ouais je fais une petite entaille et je
saigne la face à une beaucoup les médias
chinois
les volleyeuses but il ya mes parents
qui m'appellent pour aller manger
j'entends et je prends des genres une
serviette le plat du coup ce sont là
mais je t'explique la serbie est elle
était blonde ça n'était rougegoutte
général
je vais tomber dans les pommes j'imagine
mon père rang dans la salle ja bye bye
qu'une tondeuse à la main et tu fais mon
bilan est ce que tu fais mes filles oui
et alors he is et voilà je t'embrasse
difool un bien entendu et c'est vrai que
voilà quel âge exactement là bas dit il
ya deux ans alors mais c'est un vrai
pour tout ce qu'il a évoqué là c'est
vrai moi je le fais au rasoir manuel est
effectivement parfois je m'accroche rien
s'ils s'accrochent sur les boulettes
vous avez vu enfin sur les d'accord oui
sur l'éboulis sur les coucougnettes vous
avez vu qu'il ya des petits trucs que
vous rappelez parmi onze pas regarder
films à penser à regarder mais si j'ai
donc ça saigne très vite et très fort
et alors j'avais essayé aussi notre
pommade pour enlever un peu les points
noirs
alors là c'est pire moi c'était tout
maintenant snabe rouge la gonfle ah
ouais ça gonfle ouais ça c'était pas mal
on remarque une idée sympa bernard ou
telle autre cas ces spécialistes people
coucougnettes mais c'est vrai